pierre moscovici député strauss kahnien
est l'invité de preuves par 3 bonsoir
merci d'être avec nous le drame japonais
bien sûr ses conséquences la relance du
débat notamment en france sur le
nucléaire nous occupons une bonne partie
de cette émission pierre moscovici
la première partie en tous les cas
ensuite guillaume tabard deseco nous
rejoindra pour évoquer votre champion
dsk qui est aussi celui des sondages les
derniers le place à des scores que vous
avez peut-être même vous de la peine à
croire
je ne sais pas 33% premier tour je
commence à être un peu fatigué tesson
d'achat vont très bien être et puis
ensuite perrine tarneaud ce camp quand
ils sont bons comme quand ils sont vingt
corps est ensuite perrine tarneaud de
public sénat sera là pour vous
interroger sur un mode plus personnel
mais bien sûr pierre moscovici vos
ambitions personnelles votre impatience
peut être aussi un seront évoqués ce que
ce que j'ai l'air un patient à vous
allez nous le dire tout à l'heure
en tous les cas parlons d'abord donc de
ce drame nucléaire que vit le japon et
de l'impact politique en france avec
nicolas sarkozy qui se déclare
convaincue de la pertinence du nucléaire
pour la france il y avait une forme
d'union sacrée sur ce sujet aujourd'hui
on constate entre l'ump et le parti
socialiste est ce que vous donc
qu'est-ce que vous saluer nicolas
sarkozy et sa prise de position au
conseil des ministres ce rappel
franchement je veux pas me positionner
par rapport au chef de l'état au
président la république ou faire l'union
sacrée
la première des choses c'est que les
japonais sont en train de vivre un drame
épouvantable et que nous devons avoir la
décence de ne pas transposer ça dans
notre débat politique national et tous
leurs avoirs avant tout une attitude de
solidarité et être prêt à répondre sur
le terrain militaire et logistique
après c'est vrai que cela pose la
question de l'énergie nucléaire et je ne
sais pas s'il ya consensus exactement ou
pas mais on peut dégager quand même un
certain nombre de points sur lequel il
faut qu'il y ait débat
premier point moi je crois profondément
qu'il y à une exigence de débat sur le
nucléaire avec deux mots qui sont
centraux transparence et sécurité
c'est beaucoup trop opaques ce qui se
passe en france et puis il ya la
question la sécurité de nos centrales
nous avons 58 centrales en france
certaines ont 30 ans certaines sont dans
des zones qui peuvent être des zones
inondables et autres qu'il y est un
audit est une bonne chose
et s'il est ce que dit le gouvernement
vous êtes satisfait mais
s'interrogeaient sur la position et de
jj bien parce que c'est comme ça
l'essentiel
et si cet audit complet que telle ou
telle centrale devait être fermé il
faudrait agir en conséquence ne peut pas
se permettre le moindre risque pour la
sécurité
enfin il y à une question qui n'est pas
traité qui est la question du mix
énergétique c'est à dire de la part de
l'énergie nucléaire dans l'énergie être
conseillés en france pour aujourd'hui je
vous donne quand même quelques chiffres
qui feront qu'on prend les choses avec
nous avons 75 % d'énergie qui vient du
nucléaire le deuxième site est le
deuxième pays le plus qu'à réaliser
celle ukraine avec 48 profond le japon
céder 30% et c'est vrai que le nucléaire
c'est formidable mais en même temps
c'est une énergie compromis qui permet
la fois de préserver des risques de co2
et qui donne de l'indépendance mais qui
aussi comporte ses propres risques et
donc il faudra oui que nous allions vers
comment dire une décroissance maîtrisés
ou en tout cas une maîtrise de
l'équilibré de notre mix énergétique on
ne peut pas dans 20 ans ou 30 ans disent
y avoir 75 % brut
vous me dites que l'énergie nucléaire
n'est pas une source d'avenir et je dis
que c'est quelque chose de fondamental
pour n'en sort pas du nucléaire en
quelques mois nyon quelques années
l'objectif il faut il faut alors écoutez
je vais corriger mon expression lui
allons vers un rééquilibrage maîtrisé
non c'est à dire faire en sorte que ce
ne soit pas plus de 50 à 60 % de notre
production électrique est bien du
nucléaire ça veut dire deux choses quand
même très importante à il faut financer
absolument des investissements massifs
dans ce qu'on appelle les énergies
renouvelables et 2 il faut changer nos
modes de consommation notamment dans le
lot d'accord et donc je ne sais pas si
c'est ça le dit le président avec lui
parce que c'est ce que vous me dites
vous en tous les cas pierre moscovici
c'est que fondamentalement vous ne
demandez pas un changement de doctrine
n'est que je ne demande pas de
renoncements dans l'air et le parti
socialiste ne demande pas de
renoncements nucléaire en revanche ce
rééquilibrage m maîtrise est nécessaire
et je crois qu'il ya pardonnez moi de le
dire
plus que des nuances entre la gauche et
la droite ce sujet là parce que en
réalité ce que dit le président de la
république ce que dit le premier
ministre que dit la ministre belge de
sueur et de transparence comme vous
voyez mais sur le mix énergétique c'est
au fond y'a pas grand chose a changé
moi je pense que dans une perspective de
long terme il faut vraiment aller vers
un équilibrage non pas la sortie du
nucléaire mais faire en sorte de
développer d'autres sources d'énergie ou
beaucoup plus qu'aujourd'hui
économisez aussi certaines sources
d'énergie qu'on vous écoute vous
cherchez quoi rassurer vos alliés verts
qui réclament un référendum avec qui le
torchon n'a pas parlé - michel rauscher
on n'est pas toujours obligé quand
survient un élément de cette nature-là
d'être uniquement dans un rapport
politiciens qui est qu'ils sont nos
alliés avec qui elles ont gouverné etc
etc
oui c'est très important mais pardonnez
moi il me semble que les français
aujourd'hui ont une vraie sensibilité
sur ces questions ont une vraie
attention à ces questions et pardonnez
moi moi j'ai pas attendu cet événement
pour penser cela il est parti socialiste
n'a pas attendu cet événement pour le
dit
bon et donc nous ne sommes pas
contrairement à ce que disent les verts
pour la sortie du nucléaire
nous ne sommes pas favorables à un
référendum sur le nucléaire
je pense que ce référendum donnera lieu
à des manipulations un peu émotive si
vous voulez et puis quelle serait la
question au fond mais nous sommes
favorables à un débat et puis un
rééquilibrage
donc si vous voulez y compris par
rapport aux verts nous ne sommes pas
dans exactement la même position
nous sommes dans la recherche de
convergences pourquoi pas sur des sujets
qui sont des sujets majeurs
ne laissons pas la question de l'énergie
propriété d'un parti politique
nous avons aussi cela dans notre code
génétique mais en même temps affirmant
nous positionner en tous les cas une
voix divergentes au parti socialiste et
aurélie filippetti d'ailleurs qui se
fait rappeler à l'ordre par martine
aubry parce qu'elle appelle à un
véritable changement de doctrine est ce
que c'est une voix isolée
est-ce qu'elle a le droit de s'exprimer
ainsi parce que j'ai fait rappeler à
l'ordre par la première secrétaire mais
à moi je n'ai jamais été très partisan
des rappels à l'ordre je pense que pas
socialiste est un parti qui a sa
diversité simplement relié aux
philippines et à partir je crois un
groupe dans le parti socialiste qui
appelle le pôle écologique qui donne des
sensibilités intéressante je crois moi
que la position adoptée par le parti
socialiste
hier est une position équilibrée je
crois aussi que relie filippetti qui
aimant du bureau national l'adopter donc
voilà
circulons je dirai pas qui a rien à voir
mais essayons de parler là dessus encore
une fois sur des sujets de fou mais le
rappel à l'ordre était inutile c'est ce
que vous voulez dire non faussée
pardonnez moi mais c'est comme nicolas
sarkozy est comme les verts j'essaie de
m'intéresser au plus au sujet de
substances on va continuer à
s'intéresser au sujet d'importance avec
la prise de position et la tentative
d'action de nicolas sarkozy on y revient
père moscovici ce je veux parler de la
libye la france s'est portée en première
ligne on l'a vu plus tôt seul est ce que
vous avez envie de rendre hommage au
chef de l'état non écoutez moi ce qui me
frappe depuis le début de cette
révolution arabe
il ya eu d'abord la tunisie et l egypte
et maintenant la libye
c'est l'espèce de côté erratique de la
diplomatie française pendant un moment
nicolas sarkozy s'est montré
terriblement complaisant avec les
régimes en place il voyait finalement le
confort des dictateurs mais le risque
des démocraties c'est ce qu'il a fait
que la tunisie
c'est ce qu'il a fait avec les gîtes là
qu'il trouvait plus que les autres a
beaucoup plus que les connaisseurs et
côté il l'a fait dans un moment qu'aucun
de ses prédécesseurs n'avait connu c'est
dire le moment où il y avait sept et
brand
on peut reprocher à tel ou tel de ses
prédécesseurs devoir parler avec
benayoun moubarak mais il n'y avait pas
arriver aujourd'hui l'urgence ni orient
mais attendez attendez attendez c'est à
dire de la tonne sur la libye il a pris
la position exactement symétrique c'est
à dire qu' il n'a pas écouté la
diplomatie française qui n'avait
d'ailleurs pas écouter avant et il a été
inspiré par des émissaires ou des
intellectuels comme bernard henri lévy
et tout à coup le voilà qui se
transforme en va-t-en-guerre solitaire
je ne dis pas que cette position est une
position qui manque de générosité mais
je crois en effet qu'il faut être
extrêmement vigoureux par rapport au
dictateur libyen mais il ya quand même
deux problèmes le premier c'est que
nicolas sarkozy dans le passé et un
passé récent a eu une à l'égard de
kadhafi
une attitude stupide c'est une attitude
également complaisant dans cet amical
qualifie aujourd'hui je crois qu'en tout
cas ça ne le qualifie pas parce que moi
j'ai été vous savez peut-être président
de la commission dont quatre
parlementaires de l'assemblée nationale
sur la libération des infirmières
bulgares qui ont été emprisonnés en
libye mais j'ai tout lieu de croire que
derrière cela y avait des accords
d'affaires notamment l'espoir de vendre
des rafale l'espoir devant des centrales
nucléaires ça a été montré de manière
très claire ça a été dit par anne
lauvergeon
un peu embarrassé devant la commission
denquête et donc hier on était très pote
avec kadhafi aujourd'hui on est très
critique mais la deuxième chose que je
voulais dire c'est que il aurait mieux
valu franchement que nicolas sarkozy
s'inscrivent dans le cadre de l'union
européenne qu'ils évitent de faire
cavalier seul et qu'il plaide avec ses
partenaires de l'union pour qu'il y ait
une zone d'exclusion aérienne que cela
soit fait aussi sur les paramètres de la
ligue arabe qu'il est une force
multipolaire qui soient mises en place
avec tenez par exemple le brésil et
l'egypte et au lieu de cela nicolas
sarkozy c'est un coup à gauche un coup à
droite est toujours tout seul et ça
c'est pas une diplomatie efficace vous
évoqué la perspectives d'affaires
derrière la libération des infirmières
aujourd'hui le clan kadhafi s'en prend à
nicolas sarkozy prend le traitent de fou
et puis lui demande de rendre l'argent à
celui que tripoli auraient versés pour
la campagne présidentielle de 2007
est-ce que vous accordez un début de
crédit à ce genre d'homme je préfère ma
science fontanes aimant et contrairement
à nicolas sarkozy je n'accorde aucune
espèce de validité à la parole de
kadhafi
et quand le président du dictateur
libyen parle
je pense qu'il s'agit toujours de
provocation mais honnêtement nicolas
sarkozy aurait mieux fait de le réaliser
car au moment où il est arrivé aux
responsabilités en 2007 et uni rue cette
libération
il y eut cet espoir fou que les choses
allaient se normaliser et qu'on allait
pouvoir négocier je vais pas parler
d'affaires des contrats mirifiques
c'était naïf c'était stupide à l'époque
et je me souviens mais vraiment ça va
vraiment fait de la peine ça m'a fait
mal vous sauver de ce spectacle absurde
de kadhafi dressant sa tente dans la
cour de l'hôtel marigny ou bien visitant
versailles avec ses moon boot et sa
chapka
mais comment nicolas sarkozy at il pu
être si naïf qu'il ait fait confiance à
ces dictateurs moi je lui fais confiance
en rien même pas quand il ya des
allégations sur une campagne électorale
d'accord mais vous ne faites pas non
plus confiance à kadhafi accusateurs
c'est bien ce que je dis je ne fais
aucune chance à kadhafi que je règle
avait pas de confiance à l'époque je ne
fais pas confiance maintenant mais mais
en même temps comment nicolas sarkozy at
il pu lui faire confiance comment at il
pu lui faire confiance et donc
aujourd'hui je dirais que du coup son
attitude paraît un peu médiatique
est-ce qu'il tournait vers la
communication plus que vers l'action et
ce qu'il est temps alors un peu en
matière d'action est ce qu'il est encore
temps d'agir militairement alors que là
les insurgés sont réprimées durement par
le par kadhafi qui envoie son artillerie
et ses avions vous avez raison tout ça
serait risible si t'es pas des vies
humaines qui sont perdus tous les jours
et moi je lance cet appel pas seulement
nicolas sarkozy mais à toute la
communauté internationale tout le monde
le dit les américains le disent l'onu le
disent il faut maintenant très très vite
qu'il y à une action qui appelle à un
cessez le feu et deux à une zone
d'exclusion aérienne
et moi je fais cette proposition que ça
se passe dans un cadre multilatéral
enfin ce que nicolas sarkozy ignore
c'est à dire avec d'autres ça doit
pouvoir être fait avec les anglais c'est
le pouvoir être fait avec l'union
européenne ce le pouvoir est fait avec
les égyptiens
je vais bien se présente de la lenteur
de la diplômée partie kadhafi y aura
déjà maté la rébellion est indispensable
que ça intervienne très très vite on est
dans l'urgence absolue là et il faut
effectivement que la communauté
internationale
arrête de tergiverser allez on va parler
du parti socialiste donc et de 2012 dans
un instant
dsk semble-t-il à ancrer l'idée
maintenant dans l'opinion qu'il était
candidat vous en avez maintenant la
conviction pierre moscovici vous même
jean genet journée l'espoir mais je suis
un député socialiste avant même d'être
un député strauss kahnien c'est à vous
avez encore un doute
tant que c'est nos réserves vous même
pour vous lancer dans les primaires
c'est pas du tout ça tant qu'il ne s'est
pas déclarée comme candidat je pense
qu'il faut pas faire comme s'il était
déjà ce serait ce serait à la fois un
délicat peut-être là aussi naïf
maladroit et donc voilà je dirais
simplement que ma conviction qu'il doit
être candidat grandit tous les jours et
ma conviction qu'ils y pensent également
bien on en parle donc avec notre
confrère des échos guillaume tabard mais
d'abord avec fabrice qu'une est plongée
dans la science de la com 1 que
maîtrisent vraiment à merveille dsk
cette fois le doute n'est plus permis
dsk a clairement fait comprendre qu'il
était candidat
le tout sans le dire derrière ce tour de
force
ils sont trois stéphane fouks ramzi
khiroun et gilles finchelstein le
premier dirige le puissant euro rscg
le second travaille pour le groupe
lagardère et le dernier s'occupe d'un
think-tank socialiste
trois hommes et une femme son attachée
de presse anne hommel
ce sont eux qui organisent sa stratégie
faut occuper l'espace montrer qu'on est
dans le jeu politique à se faire un peu
désirer créer le désir comme diraient
les publicitaires et en même temps ne
pas se dévoiler alors qu'est ce que l'on
fait on occupe quelques séquences on
envoie quelques cartes postales comme on
dit en communication au sénat ils sont
une trentaine à former un club de
soutien à sa tête le fidèle françois
patriat pour lui la stratégie de com à
un objectif je crois que ce qu'il lui
fallait rétablir
face aux accusations sur le fait que
dominique seuret est lointain avec
strauss kahn il fallait rétablir la
vérité montrer en quoi les problèmes
qu'ils traitent aujourd'hui sont les
problèmes quotidiens des français par
ailleurs à chaque séquence dsk s'emploie
à casser son image de patron du fmi à se
donner une dimension plus sociale en
france plus de 6
lyon un quart des salariés gagnent moins
de 750 euros
dans cette situation là il ya une sorte
de mécanique négative qui se met en
marche et c'est contre ça qu'il faut
lutter ses sorties médiatiques à gaza
droite et parfois même à gauche
la dernière fait beaucoup parler un an
avec dsk
ou comment humaniser le patron du fmi
une commande de canal+ mais l'équipe de
com n'aurait pas fait mieux
yes we can moi j'ai su pourrions ils ont
fait ça est ce que vous en pensez de ce
slogan il a servi une fois peut pas
servir deux fois
voilà il est vraiment très fort au
niveau de la comme un guillaume tabard
nous a rejoint saint pierre moscovici
alors vous avez dit tout à l'heure à
michel que vous étiez lassé par les
sondages donc on doit pas commencer par
parler des sondages mais revenons sur
cette séquence de communication je suis
pas lassé par les sondages ce que je
veux dire c'est que ce qu'il mesure
surtout aujourd'hui c'est quatre choses
la première c'est le discrédit
fantastique qui frappent nicolas sarkozy
on ne sait pas où ça va s'arrêter enfin
le voilà 18 19 % c'est ça quelque chose
d'effrayant pour lui et pour la fonction
présidentielle
la deuxième chose que sa mesure c'est la
montée du front national et mois avant
d'être parmi vous là ce soir je suis
tous les jours en soutien à l'économie
aux cantonales même plusieurs fois par
jour et je constate ça sur le terrain et
j'avoue que ça m'effraie j'ai été mise
au sport j'ai vécu le 22 avril je ne
veux pas le revivre la troisième chose
que sa mesure
c'est que s'agissant du parti socialiste
et de ses candidats disons sur le
terrain français s'est pas encore
totalement convaincant et la quatrième
chose c'est qu'il y a une valeur que je
ne sais pas comment appeler refuge
recours ou puissante qui essaient de
domique strauss kahn voilà la réalité
après ce long de ces 30 32 33 à la fin
on finit par par la déferlante si vous
voulez moscovici a proposé avant tout
une déferlante antisarkozyste oui mais
justement à propos de votre deuxième
point sur la montée du front national
est ce que le parti socialiste peut dire
que c'est la cause de nicolas sarkozy
c'est ce qu'on entend pas pas uniquement
moi je que je mesure c'est une
désespérance sociale c'est une france
qui a peur du déclassement
c'est un racisme il faut le dire aussi
qu'ils gagnent du terrain mais c'est
vrai que le président de la république a
laissé se développer un terrain
particulièrement désagréable et propice
au fn quand ils ne cessent de lancer des
débats lamentables comme le débat sur
l'identité nationale comme le débat sur
l'islam et la laïcité quand justement
s'agissant des révolutions arabes
au lieu de dire d'emblée voilà c'est une
espérance est une chance et nous devons
construire une puissante actions euro
méditerranéenne il dit attention au
risque migratoire comme s'il y avait un
risque de déferlement de tout à l'heure
je participe et un débat à l'assemblée
nationale avec alain juppé qui nous dit
pas du tout la même chose
on parlait tout à l'heure de la
politique étrangère la france
aujourd'hui à deux voies qui ne sont pas
du tout en cohérence
ben oui le présent la république et le
deal première intéressée le ministre des
affaires étrangères salaire de l'agacer
beaucoup
lagacé quand je lui ai dit mais je pense
néanmoins que c'est la vérité sur tous
les sujets sur la libye sur le japon est
sûr sur les flux migratoires sur
l'europe il ya deux voies enfin en
attendant la principale c'est celle du
président de la république et je pense
que tout ça est anxiogène et que oui
nicolas sarkozy je l'accuse
je l'accuse non pas d'être le seul
responsable de la montée du fn mais d'en
être un des principaux responsables
parce que il ne tient pas son rôle de
gardien des valeurs républicaines
liberté égalité fraternité laïcité la
discorde chez l'ennemi ce qui est de
bonne guerre en politique oui est ce que
c'est mais est-ce que si cette personne
de marine le pen n'est pas due aussi à
un exode des catégories des catégories
populaires venus de la gauche qui vont
vers marine le pen est ce que de ce
point de vue de niches fiscales est le
mieux placé pour parler à cet électorat
populaire
je serai le vraiment le dernier à être
comme ça négligeant par rapport à ça je
suis élue d'une circonscription où jean
marie le pen a fait 29 % 29% vous
m'entendez en 2002 alors que le mieux la
jeune femme faisait 15 et jacques chirac
donc je sais ce que c'est et je sais que
cette souffrance des couches populaires
elle existe et je dis que nous parti
socialiste nous devons y répondre
donc je ne néglige pas mais s'agissant
de microscan vous savez moi je les
connais ses électeurs ce sont les miens
dans le paiement veut dire ce sont des
électeurs ouvriers souder les électeurs
populaires sont des lecteurs qui vit
dans les conditions difficiles
ils attendent aussi une parole de
réassurance une parole d'autorité une
parole de solidarité et ce que disent
les sondages
aujourd'hui c'est pas dans mes
prédictions 10 ans du monde est sonné et
je suis sûr encore une fois quand j team
là c'est que il ya un côté quand même à
force de déferlante où tous les jours on
voit des choses c'est quand même un peu
fatigant vous voyez comme ces tendances
l'autre que j'ai donné ce que disent les
sondages tous c'est que dominique
strauss kahn peut incarner sa y compris
à l'égard des couches populaires
et figurez vous que cet homme-là qu'on
dit lointain qu'on dit hommes du fmi je
ne sais quelle gouvernance mondiale web
2 com
il est aussi celui qui est le plus
populaire dans l'électorat socialiste
héritera ouvriers c'est ainsi il faut
pas comme sa caricature et les choses
aient pensé que cet électorat il a des
oeillères il est disponible pour une
parole de vérité
j'en suis profondément convaincu par
contre si on lui tient des discours trop
classique des discours d'assistanat
secours plan plan des discours fatigué
alors là ils se détournent du courant
socialiste et le parti socialiste a
besoin de rénover sa parole
profondément j'en suis intimement
persuadé et pas depuis hier cette montée
de marine le pen a également relancé le
débat interne au parti socialiste sur le
bien fondé des primaires alors vous même
vous avez dit rapidement qu'il fallait
que ces primaires aient lieu même temps
j'avais dit c'était à lyon je crois hier
que le ps ne pouvaient pas se payer le
luxe d'une confrontation entre des
candidats d'une même sensibilité alors
clairement qu' alors je ne cesse de
répéter la même chose après si si si si
si si non non si michel grossiord parce
que on m'a prêté des propos
invraisemblables
j'ai toujours dit la même chose j'ai été
un des premiers à demander les prix le
droit d'être candidate en europe et scc
moi vous dire une chose
nous avons décidé les primaires parce
que ça permettait d'élargir la palette
de ceux qui votent pour le candidat
socialiste ça lui donne une légitimité
démocratique populaire beaucoup plus
forte
j'étais partisan des primaires je le
reste que les choses soient claires
après qui dit primaire dippach chienlit
n'y pas division dit pas en fout sur la
gueule
et justement dans cette tournée que je
fais des cantons français
j'étais hier dans la loire j'étais à
mentir dans le rhône partout on me dit
attention à vos primaires ça doit pas
être la foire d'empoigné napata division
et ça veut dire quoi
qui se souvient aujourd'hui tout le
monde est légitime à nenê simplement ce
que j'ai appelé ce à quoi j'ai appelé et
j'appelle à nouveau c'est la
responsabilité je prononce ce mot parce
que ça se fera peut-être encore une
reprise res ponsable unités on n'est pas
obligé d'être candidat aux primaires
pour le plaisir et donc je souhaite que
le moment venu
qu'est-ce que vous êtes à françois
hollande il justement je souhaite que le
moment venu ceux qui pensent aux
primaires soient capables de se poser la
question est ce que ma candidature est
utile d'accord et si on réussit dans
l'atelier mais pardonnez moi qui vendent
à la une du journal gratuit métro je
suis prêt je vous réponde de manière
très claire si on reste dans la
situation d'aujourd'hui vous avez un
homme qui a dix points d'avancé sur les
autres dans les sondages les fameux
sondages
si on reste à la situation d'aujourd'hui
où les trois autres sont dans une équipe
ans à peu près comme lui ils sont
peut-être prêts ils ont envie ça se
comprend moi je comprends tout à fait
les ambitions légitimes de martine aubry
de françois hollande de ségolène royal
et voyez où quelqu'un comme moi n'a pas
de raison de ne pas y penser mais qu'on
raisonne en
responsabilité si soi même on est
talonné par le fn
pendant que quelqu'un nous prémunit de
ça alors il faut se mettre derrière lui
donc j'en appelle à des primaires de
responsabilité de rassemblement ça veut
pas dire qu'il faut le décider demain
matin mais ça veut dire que au moment où
se lanceront vraiment les candidatures
fin juin il faut quand même que tout le
monde se pose la question quel et non
pas mon intérêt personnel mais l'intérêt
général l'intérêt collectif
l'intérêt de gauche je sais que ça
paraît totalement ringard et stupide
fatigués ce que je dis enfin quand même
les notions d'intérêt général sont pas
des notions nul droit social il me dit
qu'il comprenait très bien
auxi même martine aubry même françois
hollande même céline royal sont talonnés
voire devancé par le front national a
fortiori un arnaud montebourg a forcé un
manuel valls à sortir et vous même de
conclusion il y en a qu'un je pense qu'à
nous et pour ce qui me concerne donc je
me suis déjà exprimé de la manière la
plus claire mais on peut avoir des
primaires sans avoir dix candidats les
primaires c'est pas juste une machine
tir aux pigeons pour offrir à la droite
le spectacle de la division de la gauche
ou même c'est quelque chose qui permet
d'élargir le champ de ceux qui
choisissent candidats on n'est pas
obligé d'en faire n'importe quoi et donc
pour ce qui me concerne
enfin là pour le coup je pense que j'ai
un peu montré l'exemple le premier tu ne
te fais pas toujours été comprise mais
j'ai toujours défendu j'ai dit oui je
veux où je pense pouvoir être candidat
aux primaires
je pense qu'il faut qu'une autre
génération puisse exprimer dans les
primaires je crois que j'ai autre chose
à dire que telle ou telle est donc qu'il
n'y a pas de raison que les primaires
soient réservés la génération qui
étaient là dans les années 80 90 je les
dis je le pense mais j'ai aussi dit
autre chose que si quelqu'un était mieux
placé que moi qui avait les mêmes idées
que moi je serai derrière lui parce que
c'est l'intérêt du parti et l'intérêt
mon pays et c'est pour ça que je le
soutiens domique strauss kahn pas par
amitié ou affectivité pas seulement mais
surtout pas raison et pourquoi est ce
que les autres ne seraient pas aussi
résonné pour moi vous dire que vous êtes
pour des primaires de confirmation
je suis pour des primaires de
responsabilité mais c'est pas un jeu no
6 au mois de juin
il apparaît que la bataille entre trois
ou quatre candidats est légitime et sans
danger qu'il y ait cette bataille entre
trois et quatre candidats
si en revanche il apparaît que c'est une
bataille imprudente que chacun la
responsabilité pour se rassembler jeu ce
sont des propos qui sont de bon sens ils
sont
quand même qu'elle vous appelez concerne
également les verts non parce que nous
avons choisi finalement de faire des
primaires socialistes mais là pour le
coup c'est une question qui se poserait
peut-être dans l'hypothèse où nous
serions encore du si sur un confortable
en mars 2012 mais pas en mars 2011
donc vous ne craignez pas rampe que avec
l'émotion créée par le drame japonais
que par allemagne que la hulot se lance
dans la bataille et pour le coup bas
prive le ps d'un un potentiel électoral
forge je suis persuadé moi que si le
parti socialiste est capable d'élaborer
un projet à la hauteur c'est à dire à la
fois très ambitieux et très crédible
parce que la situation est très
compliquée très socialiste mais aussi
très écologique
je suis persuadé que si nous sommes
capables de faire ça et si nous sommes
capables de choisir dans de bonnes
conditions
notre candidat à l'élection
présidentielle alors que m'ont dit dans
la guerre des étoiles la force est en
nous elle sera avec nous et nous n'avons
pas besoin à ce moment là de chercher
des combinaisons politiques
si nous ne sommes pas capables de ça
nous serons en difficulté de toute façon
c'est pour ça que moi j'appelle à une
sortie par le haut si vous voulez de nos
crises crise identitaire crise de
leadership
ça fait dix ans que nous trimbalons ça
en réalité depuis le 21 avril 2002 nous
avons quelques mois pour en sortir et
moi j'appelle franchement mes amis mes
camarades en sortir par l'eau
franchement je n'y a pas que président
la république dans la vie alors une
question de calendrier chose quoi si si
si par extraordinaire ou si comme c'est
ce que je souhaite
martine aubry françois hollande ou
ségolène royal moi même
manuel valls se retirer et vous pensez
qu'il n'y a pas de boulot pour tout le
monde moi je proxy une question de
calendrier
on se souvient que vous voyez vous alors
demain autres votre boulot c'est ce à
quoi je mon parmi boulot c'est de
commencer à essayer de contribuer à
faire gagner le candidat socialiste
moi j'ai appris que vendre la peau de
l'ours avant de l'avoir tué vous savez
quand j'étais dans la pièce le 21 avril
2002 j'étais un jeune miss de jospin
probablement premier à l'époque bon
avenir et quinze jours après je n'étais
plus des plus quand vous entendez
aujourd'hui françois fillon évoqué
ouvertement le risque d'un 21 avril mais
à l'envers pour la droite
je me dis qu'il ya de l'inquiétude et
vous savez je parle toujours de ce que
je vois sur le terrain je sens
respectivement que cette montée du front
national
elle se fait en partie sur la gauche et
beaucoup sur la droite et c'est pour ça
que l'attitude de nicolas sarkozy j'y
reviens à l'issue
il est irresponsable parce que vous
savez quand on lance certains débats et
qu'on y donne pas de réponse parce qu'en
fait quand jean françois copé jean
l'islam la laïcité mon change rien
josiane et marine le pen qu'est ce que
dit derrière mais moi je vous donne une
réponse simpliste contre les valeurs de
la droite mais en réalité les français à
la fin préfèrent toujours l'original à
la copie
si c'est pour faire du le pen light
alors à ce moment-là ils feront du le
pen
haarde et ça je reproche à la droite de
ne pas l'avoir compris
françois fillon me paraît plus prudent
simplement il est il peut pas dire
grand chose sinon s'inquiéter il
s'inquiète peut-être pour la sarthe
aussi et en même temps pour françois
fillon dire ça est-ce que c'est pas une
manière aussi ve d'attirer manière
peut-être pas charitable l'attention sur
la situation de près dans la république
peut-être vous savez il faut raisonner
dans plusieurs cas de figure tout laisse
à penser que nicolas sarkozy veut être
candidat à un deuxième mandat
tout laisse à penser qu'il va l'être
simplement il est aujourd'hui dans une
des faveurs tel qu'il n'est pas à l'abri
d'un mauvais coup de la droite
souvenez-vous des 43 députés qui à
l'époque avait laissé tomber
jacques chaban delmas pour aller sur
valéry giscard d'estaing comment
s'appelait déjà le chef de ce petit
groupe jacques chirac chirac
voilà vous pensez que françois fillon
exprime une envie pré présidentielle moi
ce que je sens c'est que à droite ya
comme beaucoup de fébrilité qu'il ya de
l'inquiétude est que nicolas sarkozy
aujourd'hui paraît davantage un boulet
ses amis qu'un atout d'ailleurs vous
savez ce qui est très drôle c'est que
vous allez dans les départements
français vous êtes la chaîne
parlementaire on ne voit nulle part le
sigle de l'ump disparus engloutis
y at il encore une majorité
présidentielle je lance ici un avis de
recherche
la situation à droite pendant longtemps
on a demandé aux responsables de l'ump
quel candidat socialiste serait le plus
dangereux le moins dangereux pour vous
aujourd'hui retournant la question pour
vous quel serait le candidat de droite
le plus dangereux ou le moins dangereux
trop tôt pour le dire mais en tout cas
nicolas sarkozy n'est pas en bonne
position c'est sûr mais en même temps
vous savez il faut d'abord fixer dur à
battre pour vous j'en sais rien mais il
faut d'abord que j'en sais rien ce que
je sais c'est que après les cantonales
si comme je le pense je le souhaite
la gauche gagne de nombreux départements
si nous sommes en situation de renverser
la majorité sénatoriale parce que ça
derrière aussi ça va commencer à tanguer
sec chez eux après c'est leur affaire
par contre un petit pronostic comme un
département
pouvoir basculer à gauche le 27 mars je
devrais pas le dire parce que l'on va
faire dans la langue de bois dix ans et
sera bien venir
je me suis déplacé dans une quinzaine de
départements j'en vois beaucoup où les
choses sont possibles mais il faut
cravacher jusqu'au bout ou presque mais
quand j'ai beaucoup c'est beaucoup merci
guillaume dernière question est ce que
vous êtes favorable à un front
républicain non non vous savez moi j'ai
voté le après le 21 avril pour jacques
chirac et j'ai appelé à voter pour lui
j'ai fait campagne pour lui on a vu
ensuite que les choses ont été vraiment
ambiguë je ne ferai jamais l'équivalence
entre la droite républicaine et le front
national
mais de là à appeler comme ça avec
enthousiasme à voter pour un candidat de
droite
il faudra trouver les bonnes formules ça
s'appellera pas convaincu monté par coup
non on peut aussi dire qu'il ya ceux des
valeurs qu'on partage pas ou peu appelé
à faire barrage
sa veux dire toute une terminologie mais
en tout cas le front républicain je ne
crois pas parce que justement la droite
républicaine abâtardie son message et
parce qu'il ya un truc ya trop peu de
différences entre le message l'ump le
message du fn entre les ressentiments et
les ressentis des militants et des
électeurs ump celui fn merci guillaume
tabard perrine tarneaud va donc nous
rejoindre juste avant bien c'est un
repère moscovici sur vous regardez moi
c'est là que sur vous je reçois par
l'internaute c'est quand même si vos
ambitions
sur vos frustrations aussi peut-être
allez savoir parti socialiste vous avez
rappelé oui vous avez rappelé le gap
générationnel qui embrument plus d'un
plus tard drid plus d'un au parti
socialiste on voit ça avec tam tran huy
pierre moscovici c'est l'histoire d'un
ex enfant précoce de la politique
cantonnée aux seconds rôles plus jeune
secrétaire national en 1990 élue au
parlement européen dès 1994
mais pas facile pour le benjamin du
gouvernement jospin de grandir dans la
famille socialiste pierre moscovici et
et ministre des affaires européennes ce
qui n'est pas une mince portefeuille
mais néanmoins il est considéré comme
étant celui qui était derrière védrine
qu'on voyait à peine et les médias et
les socialistes considèrent qu'un type
qui n'a été que ministre des affaires
européennes excusé quand même dû peut à
nouveau
c'est comme s'ils n'avaient rien fait en
2008 pierre moscovici tente
l'émancipation en se déclarant candidat
à la tête du parti
mais la révolte adolescente et la barbe
naissante à 50 ans n'aboutissent pas au
succès escompté dans le chaos général
des socialistes moscow et laissé sur le
bord du chemin
il y aurait il un problème de génération
les jeunes lions les ex quadra
aujourd'hui qu'un cas ont bien du mal à
se faire entendre pour eux mêmes la
faute aussi peut-être aux médias tant
qu'ils étaient mouche du coche ou ou
porteur d'eau ou celui qu'on pouvait
joindre au téléphone plus facilement que
son chef
il avait une certaine surface médiatique
à partir du moment où il revendique
quelque chose c'est à dire le droit à
l'existence politique il ya un tir de
barrage médiatique
aujourd'hui pierre moscovici a des
responsabilités au ps mais s'il revient
sur le devant de la scène c'est aussi
parce que l'ex outsider s'est transformé
en porte voix de l'homme providentiel
principe de réalité oblige et si cette
stratégie s'avérait efficace pierre
moscovici pourrait prétendre à des
responsabilités de premier plan dans
très longtemps au moins à lyon on l'a
dit mais genre que l'on n'arrivera
jamais au premier plan et sera toujours
au second plan dans l'eau voyez je suis
devenu maire de lyon vous dira peut-être
dans quelques années pour pierre
moscovici redire mais là encore là comme
quoi il faut toujours se méfier de l'eau
qui dort voilà
et pour lui son graal politique c'est là
mais les lions le vôtre c'est quoi
toujours faire mieux demain que ce que
j'ai fait hier je n'ai pas vraiment
l'impression si vous voulez être
aujourd'hui un second rôle y avoir été
confiné les commentaires de monsieur
bernard me font droit au coeur
mais non en réalité ce qui est vrai
c'est qu'il y a dans notre parti d'un
problème de génération c'est que nous
sommes à parti unique qui ne se compare
à aucun autre mois j'étais le plus jeune
ministre socialiste lionel jospin est
émise affaires européennes je continue à
voir beaucoup de contacts européens et
ce que je vois c'est que tous ces partis
contrairement à nous renouveler leur
leadership
une fois deux fois trois fois prenez
l'exemple par exemple du parti
travailliste britannique où il ya eu
deux frères qui sont affrontés l'un avec
un an tan l'hôtel 45 ans le premier
ministre a 45 ans et le vice premier
ministre à 45 ans nous en france souvent
un côté un peu relais d'un pays anglo
saxons rien turnover un jeu plus
important pour le chez les hommes
politiques qu'en france je ne connais
pas en europe deux partis qu'ils soient
dirigés par les mêmes qu'il ya dix ans
aux 12 ans nous sommes un peu
l'exception il ya un côté un peu
politburo et c'est vrai que l'on laisse
peu les jeunes qui sont plus très jeune
mais parce que sa veste originale les
cadres à des postes socialistes ils sont
qu'un 415 et voilà c'est pas un cliché
finalement ces quinquas qui sont rester
éternellement dans l'antichambre du
pouvoir qui rongent leur frein
c'est vrai que la façon dont le pouvoir
se construit chez nous à un peu étouffé
une génération
est ce que je veux dire ici c'est que
cette génération à laquelle j'appartiens
mais je suis pas seul on a vu vincent
peillon l'a vu arnaud montebourg n'a lui
rien de mal sur vous ça nous arrive
mais cette génération n'a pas vocation à
jouer les seconds rôles pour le coup en
2012 si nous l'emportons parce que la
victoire que j'appelle de mes voeux
autour dominique strauss kahn
effectivement parce que je pense qu'il
est mieux placé ça ne doit pas ça ne
peut pas être la restauration ou le
remake le 97 15 ans après ça n'aurait
aucun sens
il faut effectivement faire qu'il y ait
de nouveaux visages nouvelles idées dans
sa lutte et certains riverains ont
émergé se sont fait un nom voir un
prénom je pense à françois hollande à
ségolène royal
le oui certes c'est si dur pour vous par
exemple d'émerger de vous fabriquer une
personnalité françois hollande a été
leader du parti socialiste pendant 11
ans et ségolène royal a été candidate à
l'élection présidentielle
et honnêtement je ne leur en veux rien
mais vraiment rien
je dis simplement que ça peut pas être
le partage des dépouilles entre
quelques-uns l'année prochaine et qu'il
faudra que tout le monde soit au
chapitre
je pense que la génération à laquelle
j'appartiens demandé quel était le graal
jeu même pas idée
mais cette génération là ne peut pas
être confinée au second rôle ça peut pas
être des gens qui ont commencé à être
député dans les années 80 min dans les
années 90 qui dirige le pays en 2012
tout seul ça n'aurait pas de sens je le
dis de manière très tranquille ayant
moi-même et el mizan gouvernement
pendant 5 ans dans une fonction dont je
peux assurer monsieur bernard qu'elle
est intéressante
alors on va revenir deux minutes à
dominique strauss kahn votre première
rencontre avec lui datent de l'ena il
était votre professeur ça a été le coup
de foudre
ça a été une rencontre amicale et puis
on a très vite sympathisé et c'est vrai
que à l'époque moi j'étais plutôt à
l'extrême gauche où vous l'avez été je
n'étais plus c'était en été quand même
82 83 g t au fonctionnaire j'avais envie
de faire quelque chose j'avais envie de
l'action mais c'est lui qui m'a fait
adhérer au parti socialiste ou plutôt
qui m'a attiré dans les cercles
d'experts socialiste c'est lui qui m'a
présenté un lionel jospin et ça fait
effectivement maintenant où là je me
rends compte près de trois décennies de
compagnonnage avec de l'amitié avec eux
aussi de l'admiration pour
l'intelligence cuba ciel avec vous et
prononcez le mot de l'émancipation
c'est pas tout à fait la même chose
quand on a soi même un peu moins de 25
ans et qu'on a un professeur et quand on
a un peu plus de 50 ans et qu'on a
quelqu'un avec qui on travaille
politiquement donc on n'a pas les mêmes
rapports qu'à l'époque mais bon en même
temps il reste sept composantes là je
suis moi quelqu'un de très ringard parce
que très fidèle en politique depuis que
je fais de la politique j'ai eu deux
amis aux mains tort lionel jospin en
2000 strauss kahn ça n'a pas beaucoup et
vous posez oui quelle place occupe
également lionel jospin dans votre
panthéon personnel très haute kankan en
86 je suis devenu le secrétaire des
gones groupe d experts je suis entre au
cabinet lionel jospin qui était mise
l'éducation nationale c'est lui qui me
fait devenir le plus jeune secrétaire
national du parti socialiste député
européen j'ai été son ministre à 39 ans
comment voudriez vous qu'ils y ont fait
ce parcours auprès de cet homme intègre
je n'ai pas pour lui reconnaissance et
amitié et je pense que c'est une figure
est extrêmement belle de la gauche
et qu'on aurait tort d'oublier parce que
somme toute il est le seul qui nous a
permis de l'emporter en 97
or du lendemain d'une élection
présidentielle et il a vraiment diriger
ce pays avec honnêteté probité et ces
valeurs-là dans la période que nous
vivons avec le sarkozysme confus elles
sont réhabilités mais justement vous
rappeliez tout à l'heure que vous
trouviez dans la même pièce que lui le
21 avril 2002 vous avez compris sa
réaction son retrait de la vie politique
sur le sur le coup et puis après un mois
j'ai mangé les compris je n'ai pas
accabler je pense que c'est un homme qui
est très honnête avec vous si des
éléments lundi parfois de rigidité et
puis il avait vécu ça comme une blessure
en plus il avait le réflexe qu'ont les
chefs de gouvernements dans les pays
anglo saxons justement vous évoquez
quand on a perdu on se retire on
s'accroche pas chez nous on a quand même
une belle tradition on s'accroche on
perd revient et c est donc il n'a fait
ça je pense qu'il a fait un peu
brutalement mais je ne lui reproche pas
simplement ce qui est vrai c'est que
c'est lui ont compliqué la vie
considérablement au moins il a voulu
revenir c'était même plus possible
et aujourd'hui comment vous jugez la
stratégie de martine aubry c'est à la
tête du parti socialiste
quelle est sa stratégie ok pas de
stratégie et non c'est pas ça que je
veux dire c'est qu'on lui prête beaucoup
de choses moi ce que je vois c'est
qu'elle est le chef du parti socialiste
et que je constate là sans doute des
ambitions martine aubry et je trouve ça
normal quand on n'est pas tellement
valeur je vais venir
quand on est comme l a été numéro deux
du gouvernement de lionel jospin
les auteurs des 35 heures grande réforme
emblématique de la gauche quand on est
aujourd'hui premier secrétaire du parti
socialiste
quand on est une femme intelligente
comme elle l'est on a envie d'exercer
les premiers rôles on a sans doute envie
de président de la république
elle a probablement envie de se
présenter aux primaires mais il ya une
chose que je lis reprenant une chose que
je lui reconnais je veux la saluer pour
ça je suis pas toujours d'accord avec
elle la son caractère la saisie d on
n'est pas toujours en phase mais je lui
reconnais une chose je veux la remercier
pour ça c'est que justement on parlait
tout à l'heure de responsabilité elle
agi avec responsabilité
je suis persuadé que martine aubry avant
de penser à elle pense à une chose c'est
la victoire de la gauche en 2012 et
qu'elle se dit que si ça passe par le
succès d'un autre qu'elle en
l'occurrence 2000 troskan elle s'y
pliera je dis pas que ce sera forcément
avec un plaisir énorme de renoncer un
destin qu'elle croit possible pour elle
et voyez vous moi
ça je dis chapeau le pacte non c'est pas
un pacte je crois que c'est surtout un
il ya eu un impact mais vous savez que
l'hôtel pâte pas que c'était de
s'entendre probablement pour gagner le
premier secrétariat du parti socialiste
et pour empêcher par exemple que
ségolène royal le deviennent je suis
persuadé qu'il ya pas de pacte sur la
présidentielle ce nom je crois pas que
tu es un impact revanche je pense que ce
sont deux personnes ils ont quand même
plus ou moins confirmés notamment
martine aubry implicitement ce break je
pense que ce que dit martine aubry doit
être écoutée pour ce qu'elle est ce que
c'est quand elle dit nous ne
présenterons pas l'un contre l'autre ça
veut dire je ne me présenterai pas
contre lui et honnêtement dans la
situation qui est la sienne
seulement deux noms pas de l'abnégation
enfin sans ses responsablités résister à
la pression de ses amis parce qu'elle
aussi elle compte des amis des élus
comme vous qui disent mais c est la
mieux placée par exemple pour réunir la
gauche notamment premier tour par
rapport à dsk
je pense qu'elle saura résister je crois
qu'elle reste en tout cas et encore une
fois dont tout ce qu'il a dit je ne n'ai
jamais vu demande le train aujourd'hui
c'est parce que j'avais déjà renoncé non
non non non non parce que je pense que
je pense qu'elle ne sait pas ce qui va
se passer est que tant qu'elle ne sait
pas ce qui va se passer parce que domine
strauss kahn on peut pas considérer
qu'un coup sûr et les candidats il je
crois qu'il y va je pense que c'est bien
mais je ne suis pas le message et demie
strauss kahn je n'en sais rien moi même
et donc si vous voulez martine aubry
elle n'a pas de raison de renoncer
simplement je crois qu'elle fait ce
qu'elle a à faire ça qu'elle prépare le
parti a exercé les responsabilités alors
avec des qualités des défauts mais
encore une fois mais pourquoi ne pas
parler on n'est pas là pour faire de
langue de bois
parler de ses qualités juste avant vous
n'avez pas par étaient des faux je vois
là son caractère at il raillé et puis
pareil par ailleurs parfois on
souhaiterait que ça bouge un peu plus
sur le jeu sur le terrain des idées mais
ce que je voulais surtout souligné sa
grande qualité
la responsabilité allez on va finir sur
l'homme pierre moscovici on sait que
vous êtes un amoureux de la vie que les
amis ont leur importance les femmes
si vous n'avez plus le temps donc je
vous demander justement à ce que sont
des aliments des éléments indispensables
qui passent parfois avant la politique
non vous savez il ya beaucoup de
stéréotypes stère on parle souvent de
moi comme je t'ai il ya 20 ans ou 30 ans
je ne vais plus en boîte de nuit le soir
donc je le dis parce que je les lui dans
des tas de portraits j'aime la vie mais
mais mais je travaille beaucoup et puis
pour ce qui est des femmes au qg des
relations tout à fait normal non pas
avec des femmes mais avec une seule à la
fois en même temps et donc voilà j'ai
compagne amy genis avec la plus grande
énergie
voilà mais en même temps je me dis
qu'est aussi parfois un côté solitaire
ça c'est pas quelque chose que je
revendique on peut avoir sa personnalité
est bon moi j'ai sans doute ça aussi
dans mon code génétique
je suis très collective dans la
politique en même temps j'aime bien lire
réfléchir de mon côté me forget
n'hésitez pas moi même et je ne déteste
pas la solitude c'est vrai comment est
ce que vous vous adaptez au pays de
montbéliard vous êtes en léger décalage
vous incarnez un peu l'establishment
carlos comme ici pas plus maintenant
j'ai mis très longtemps mais vous savez
on dit en ce départ non non pas
réducteur des qualités de martine aubry
en a une que je crois on peut me
reconnaître c'est vrai que nous ne
ressemblions pas le pays de montbéliard
et moi je suis parisien de naissance
mais aussi avec quatre grands parents
d'origine étrangère
je suis énarque je suis très européiste
et ce territoire ouvriers
rob bell à l'europe parfois inquiète pas
la mondialisation il y avait des points
de différence mais j'ai toujours été
très fidèle
dans les défaites comme dans les
victoires je me suis accroché et j'ai
des questions et je me suis énormément
défoncer pour eux aujourd'hui je suis
député dans une circonscription sarkozy
devrait quand même les 54%
je suis président de l'agglomération les
gens savent que je bosse pour eux et
cette greffe compliquée elle a pris
savez il ya un fondamental mambo salsa
m'a appris des choses incroyables
on parlait justement de ces stéréotypes
qui ont 20 ans 30 ans je ne suis pas le
même et je le dois beaucoup au pays de
montbéliard parce que justement paris
n'est pas la province la province n'est
pas paris les milieux populaires
non je plus le même je suis plus le même
intimement c'est à dire que quand je
suis à paris je suis député jeu
responsables politiques nationales
voient la réalité de la vie dans des
territoires qui sont un peu plus un
combat blake parce que complexe d'une
part si physiquement de paris un
complexe et difficile et parce que ces
gens qui sont dans la difficulté
moi je travaille avec eux je travaille
pour et croyez moi c'est une chose qui
est extrêmement importante quoi qu'il
arrive au lit on est mercredi soir le
jeudi matin je pars là bas
et personne ne peut me joindre aucun
journaliste ray du tout je me consacre
totalement et je le fais parce que sam
apprend énormément mais aussi parce que
je me dévoue à ça avec un grand plaisir
et vous n'avez toujours pas de permis de
conduire ce que tu gonfles très rapide
peugeot c'est vrai mes adversaires sont
toujours là pour me le reprocher ça
m'empêche pas d'être élu rejet très bien
merci beaucoup car moscovici merci père
et une bande sera tous et la semaine
prochaine